do you ever coach your kids or do you
stay away from that no um i try to be
very present you know in this second
chapter for me in their lives that's how
my dad was to me i coached my son's flag
football team i helped out with my
daughter's softball team uh it's a lot
of fun it's a great way to spend time
with your kids although i got to tell
you kelly some of the parents i think
of the other kids on the team were a
little hesitant at first because
the last time they really saw me ever
doing any coaching
was on this saturday night live skit
where i was pegging
seven-year-old kids in the head with
footballs and i think these parents are
like are we sure we want our kid to play
on your team i'm like it was saturday
night live it was a spoof skit relax i'm
not gonna do that to your kids wait so
probably not we actually pulled that
video because it's awesome let's see a
bit of that snl sketch if you missed
why is the it open close the door
i got to be honest with you if you were
my kids coach i'd laugh at that
[Music]